and they're it's lovely to see you here
at collector mania if you've had so many
great scenes on Game of Thrones it's
course there was that moment a few
seasons back where you chopped off Jaime
Lannister's hand what was that like
filming that ah yeah that that was
probably my favorite scene and it was
actually the very first scene I did and
it was good in a way to start you know a
lot of the stuff is a lot of a lot of
extras a lot of people so it's a bit
more chaotic but that was a good you
know acting scene because it was just
basically the three of us and and it was
with David and Dan too so it was a nice
way to you know be introduced to the
series what was it like working with
Nikolaj
yeah Nicola is great he's yeah he's got
a funny sense of humor but I think
that's because they're in this sort of
Scandinavia or Nordic humor really
doesn't translate sometimes but um yeah
me and Gwen sort of pick on him a lot
but he's he's a big puppy really sweet
guy and then of course we saw you with
Brienne tossing Brienne into the bear
pit as well
yeah he's not he's not a very nice guy
like I actually know Gwen from you know
outside of the show years ago and I
hadn't seen her for years so that was it
was actually you know nice to know her
so I could get away with being a bit of
a brute to her yeah very well I mean of
course you didn't have the bear actually
they did you know there was no bear at
the time but yeah they used the real
bear in America
CGI trickery isn't it it's great they
look fantastic on the screen of course
this season we've seen you get the chop
well not quite the chop more the
strangle the throttled by Hodor yeah
yeah you know get my neck snapped and
stuff by Hodor and again you know like
if you're gonna get killed it's good to
get killed by a sort of a likeable
character in a way you know if you're if
you're the bet if a baddie sort of
things so it's yeah it's a satisfying
way to end tell me a little bit about
behind the scenes filming that I mean
how did they do the broken neck and what
was it like filming with Christian I was
going for it Christian's really lovely
guy and it's just I mean it's just
mainly it's like spending a lot of time
in prosthetics to get listen oh yeah you
probably don't even really see it and
you know winching up and all that sort
of stuff
you're fitted weren't you for a broken
spinal column processing yeah yeah I I
went before the season started they said
our you know we'd like you to go along
to the prosthetic sing and and that's
that's always I could dead giveaway
you know something Bad's gonna happen to
you when you have to get fitted for a
when they want to cast your whole head
or something you know that yeah
something Bad's going to happen to you
unless you're gonna grow another head
but I didn't think that was gonna happen
now the qualities that you need to
survive in Game of Thrones are very
particular aren't they I mean if you
could say obviously Locke didn't have
them cuz we've now wave goodbye to him
what do you think you need to survive in
Game of Thrones gosh I don't know I mean
I'm it's really well one thing if it's a
really really established character and
they live throughout in the books then
it's quite hard to kill those characters
because the fans are very you know
particular about deviating too much from
the book but
yeah I don't think anyone's safe really
like you know I think after like well
after the first season Sean Bean gets
killed once you do that to sort of a
main character then it's it's gloves off
for anyone really I think and then the
red wedding it's like yeah nobody's
nobody's safe really yeah I mean maybe
you feel like a I don't know babies get
killed in it though they yeah nobody's
safe nothing is safe definitely I mean
George RR Martin's talked about the
possibility of a game of Thrones movie
you know taking on from the show what do
you think about that and what kind of
thing would you like to see on the big
screen well I mean I I don't really know
I mean I think you know personally I
think what's made a lot of the HBO
series like going right back to the
Sopranos is the serialization of the
sort of you know length of time it takes
to tell each sees and allows you to
develop a narrative in a way that you
could never do with the film and so I
think if they did the film's it would
probably have to work a little bit like
the Star Wars films or something where
they're where the films themselves are
like chapters in a way so I don't
imagine you could do a lot with one film
you know or you'd have to be very have
to be very specifics in a little moment
you